en 1936
à princeton aux états unis la plus
grande université américaine einstein
est réfugié depuis trois ans
et il est une légende déjà il est très
connu il est inabordable difficile à il
est protégé mais une petite fille veut
lui poser une question à une question
importante
et elle arrive à se faufiler à un moment
et elle crie vers lui m m
m est ce que vous croyez en dieu
alors einstein est un peu surpris bien
sûr mais il lui répond gentiment il lui
dit mais tu poses une très belle
question une question importante je peux
pas te répondre comme ça donne moi ton
adresse et je vais te répondre mais par
écrit
et
une dizaine de jours après la petite
fille reçoit une lettre avec cet écrit
d'einstein qui est aujourd'hui
mondialement célèbre dans laquelle il
écrit toute personne sérieusement
impliqués en sciences finira par
découvrir qu'un esprit supérieurement
intelligent infiniment plus grand que
celui de l'homme se manifeste dans les
lois de l'univers
alors ça c'est une idée qui est très
forte c'est une idée qui l'a exprimé en
premier mais qui a été qui est un peu le
résumé des 100 ans qui ont changé la
science un esprit intelligente qui se
trouve derrière les lois et ses
manifestes dans les lois de l'univers
donc en fait je vais vous commenter un
petit peu ce schéma je vous parlais d'un
riche est celui de la science un reset
qui est pas un petit reset qui est
quelque chose qui sait sur la question
spécifique de l'existence de dieu alors
si on prend un tableau historique si on
regarde un peu dans l'histoire il ya eu
de la science en mésopotamie chez les
grecs dans le monde arabe en chine mais
après la période barbare c'est dans le
monde chrétien dans l'occident que la
science moderne s'est développée à
partir du moyen-âge les gens croyaient
au logo s'ils croyaient que dieu était
rationnel et qu'il avait fait un monde
rationnel il a eu des universités qui se
sont créés et la science à progresser
jusqu'à copernic et de copernic à freud
les découvertes nouvelles ont été
stupéfiante et elles ont bousculé la
religion en fait en elle-même elle
n'avait rien contre la religion
l'héliocentrisme d'évolution mai
premièrement ça changer la vision du
monde des gens c'est à dire qu'ils
étaient déstabilisés par les découvertes
nouvelles deuxièmement la science
semblait se mettre à répondre à des
questions auxquelles on penserait qu'il
y avait jamais de réponse des questions
qu'on n'aurait pas imaginé possible de
traiter et elle en faisait de plus en
plus y avait une idée de progrès on
s'était peut-être qu'elle va répondre à
toutes les questions la science et en
plus en répondant à tout ça elle avait
pas besoin de l'hypothèse de dieu vous
savez c'est l'histoire de la place avec
napoléon la place s'il va voir napoléon
et lui expose son système et napoléon
réagi en disant m'enfin je comprends pas
newton avait parlé de dieu vous vous en
parlait pas et il dit sir j'ai pas eu
besoin de cette hypothèse donc on avait
une science qui pendant toute une
période s'est développée répondez à
beaucoup de questions la science avait
aussi un prestige énorme parce qu'elle a
changé nos vies elle a changé le monde
ça a donné un courant matérialiste
extrêmement puissant qui est
scientifique aussi qui a dominé au 19e
et 20e siècles
quand on arrive en 1900 les
scientifiques pensent qu'ils ont fait le
tour de la question vous avez lord
kelvin qui à un moment dit la science
est achevée nous avons mis en équation
tous les secrets éternel de la matière
et du ciel il dit la physique c'est
terminé il faut plus qu'à ajuster les
décimales et puis d'autres se sont sur
le même registre vous avez berthelot un
grand chimiste qui dit la chimie s'est
terminée une bonne et moi dix ans pour
achever la science et puis max born et
plein plein d'autres donc on était dans
une illusion totale parce que derrière
ça il va y avoir six ou sept révolution
majeure c'est la courbe qui remonte donc
ça commence avec la thermodynamique qui
est un média mix est une science qui né
au 19e siècle mais qui avec carnot
clausus boltzmann et l clausus pose le
second principe c'est à dire que
l'entropie est toujours croissante dans
un système fermé en l'absence d'apport
d'information et là ça veut dire que il
ya une flèche du temps c'est à dire
qu'on va vers ce qu'on appelle la mort
thermique de l'univers toutes les
étoiles les unes après les autres vont
s'éteindre
ebersman comprends très bien tout de
suite il dit si jamais on va vers la
mort thermique ça veut dire qu'il ya un
début à l'univers et la question du
début elle est capital parce que s'il ya
un début au temps à l'espace et à la
matière alors il ya un dieu toutes les
visions à thé du monde sans aucune
exception toujours pensé que le monde
était éternel dans le passé donc
boltzmann mais un coup là dedans tout ça
et en plus il dit ben si l'ordre l'ordre
spécifique des croix ça veut dire qu'au
moment du début il y avait un ordre très
particulier au tout début bon ça n'a pas
un impact très fort beaucoup de gens le
combat de finalement il se suicide après
il ya une deuxième révolution très forte
c'est la mécanique quantique dans
l'infiniment petit on s'aperçoit que le
monde le réel en fait il est voilée il
ne peut pas accéder à la réalité ultime
en plus il est probabiliste il ya des
fonction d'onde et il est pas
déterministe c'est à dire quand on fait
des mesures ou canton en côte en atomes
se désintègre on peut pas changer tes en
moins tu es donc ça bouscule aussi les
idées matérialiste troisième révolution
colossal celle d'einstein einstein avec
d'autres voies l'idée de la relativité
restreinte c'est à dire que la lumière
la vitesse de la lumière est un absolu
donc ça veut dire que le temps est
relatif et puis par contre tout seul en
1915 il postule la relativité générale
et là c'est une révolution c'est à dire
qu'ils expliquent que l'espace est
courbé par la masse
en gros si on va rentrer dans les
équations d'einstein mais ce qu'il est
en train de dire c'est que le temps
l'espace et la matière sont liés ils
peuvent pas exister l'instant les deux
autres ça s'est jamais aucun philosophe
jamais aucun penseur n'avait pensé à ça
c'est quelque chose de complètement
nouveau vous explique que si vous êtes
près du soleil le temps passe moins vite
si vous êtes dans un trou noir il
s'arrête si vous avez la vitesse de la
lumière où le temps s'arrête aussi c'est
des idées complètement folle ils sont
l'intuition d'einstein qui sont mis en
théorie puis en équation il fait des
prévisions elles sont très vite vérifier
maintenant tout le monde est d'accord
il ya plus de débat sur sa si vous
voulez on est sûr que ça marche alors
cette révolution elle en amène une
quatrième qui est l'idée de l'expansion
de l'univers
personne n'avait jamais pensé à ça
einstein n'y croyait pas lui-même il
avait rajouté bidouiller un peu ces
équations pour papier d'expansion mais
un génie russe alexander friedman va un
des quatre ou cinq qui arrive à
comprendre vraiment les équations
d'einstein à l'époque à l'âge de 33 ans
à peine à 16 ans il publiés dans les
plus grandes revues mathématiques du
monde à 33 ans il fait un article qui va
et qui dépose la revue de physique
allemande le 29 mars 1922 c'est à dire
pratiquement 100 ans jour pour jour par
rapport à notre date d'aujourd'hui et
dans cet article pour la première fois
il explique que l'univers est en
expansion est qu'au début c'était
certainement un point alors ça tout le
monde personne n'y croit ça paraît
complètement farfelu mais après avec
l'aide de l'abbé le maître avec l'aide
de découverte un peu impromptue comme
celle de wilson du rayonnement de fond
cosmologique d abondance et tout ça je
vous passe les détails mais c'est très
s'est confirmée au bout de quelques
décennies aujourd'hui tout le monde est
d'accord il ya eu un big bang alors tout
ça pose d'immenses question s'il ya une
expansion de l'univers comme ça qu'est
ce qui va se passer après alors les gens
pensent que peut-être il y aura une
contraction à un moment et qu'on va
alterner ainsi que de big bang et de big
crunch mais en 1998 on s'aperçoit
qu'après neuf milliards d'années
l'univers a réaccéléré au lieu de ce
haut lieu de se contracter part
peut-être la courbure ou peut-être la
gravité en fait pas du tout si on suit
les équations ça va continuer à
accélérer le sans cesse et puis dans les
années 2000 il y avait théorème de
cosmologie qui sortent pour dire que si
le big bang était pas le début absolue
s'il y avait d'autres big bang avant le
big bang il y en a pas un nombre infini
il ya forcément un début au temps à
l'espace et à la matière des choses
complètement étonnante que jamais on
n'aurait pensé qu'on pouvait traiter en
sciences alors qu'est ce qui se passe
après ceux qui découvrent que le big
bang est vrai reprennent les équations
en particulier robert dit que et il
calcule que si jamais un instant après
le big bang la vitesse d'expansion de
l'univers et échanger du 15e chiffres
après la virgule dans un sens ou dans
l'autre on serait plus là pour en parler
quand le gars il tombe de sa chaise et
dit qu'est ce que c'est que cette chose
ce réglage est derrière lui il ya des
dizaines de scientifiques qui vont faire
des dizaines de découvertes qui vont
dire la même chose c'est-à-dire que les
vingt ou trente constante ou paramètres
qui déterminent l'univers et les forces
de l'univers si vous voulez changer un
tout petit peu on sait le modéliser
aujourd'hui on a mis ça dans des
ordinateurs l'univers se détraque ça
marche plus alors on appelle ça le
réglage fin de l'univers sap aux
d'immenses question qui comment pourquoi
ce réglage et puis encore une révolution
en biologie en biologie on pensait que
le passage de l'inerte au vivant était
quelque chose de très simple
en fait on s'aperçoit que c'est un
gouffre immense il faut passer de
l'inerte à une cellule parce que tout ce
qui est vivant sur la terre des
bactéries à l'homme en passant par
toutes les plantes et tous les animaux
ces composés de cellules mais une
cellule c'est pas rien il ya toujours de
l'adn or la dnc un langage ultra
compliqué qui est née il ya 3,8
milliards d'années de manière parfaite
qui codent tout le vivant et qui est
sorti des lois de l'univers pour vous
donner une idée la densité
d'informations dans l'adn ses 44 mille
milliards de fois plus grand que ce que
l'homme fait de plus dense au 21ème
siècle un prodige de technologie mais
l'adn ça suffit pas il faut aussi qu'ils
aient des protéines des enzymes une
membrane du métabolisme fais c'est un
truc de fou donc on est passé d'une rive
à l'autre on est passé de l'inerte aux
vivants mais c'est à cause de réglage
fin qui sont encore plus faim que les
réglages de la physique tout ça pose
d'immenses question il ya aussi une
révolution en mathématiques avec google
qui montre le parler théorème
d'incomplétude est une preuve
anthologique aussi sur dieu bon passons
vite alors si on fait le bilan il ya
deux choses premièrement l'univers est
mille fois plus complexe que ce qu'on
pensait il ya un siècle c'est sans
rapport et on s'est peut-être qu'on
saura jamais tout parce qu'à chaque fois
qu'on ouvre une question on en a trois
qui apparaissent et deuxièmement parmi
tout ce bazar toutes ces découvertes y
en a deux qui sont fondamentales pour
notre sujet c'est qu'il ya un dédit a
très certainement un début au temps à
l'espace et à la matière on le sait par
la science mais on le sait aussi par la
rationalité les mathématiques la
physique puis la thermodynamique et la
cosmologie dont je vous ai parlé s'il ya
un début au temps à l'espace et à la
matière ça veut dire que cette émergence
a été provoquée par une cause qui est
transcendante à tout ça qui est ni
temporel ni spatiale ni matériel qui a
eu la puissance de créer tout ce qui
existe et qui en plus tout réglé pour
que les atomes puisse être stable pour
que les étoiles puisse brûler 10
milliards d'années et pour que la vie
complexe puisse se développer toutes
choses qui sont totalement improbable on
le sait aujourd'hui donc ça ça pose des
questions énorme des questions
gigantesque et c'est un véritable
retournement de la science alors quand
on regarde le paysage
aujourd'hui si vous regardez le monde
vous avez l'impression que cette
question des licences de dieu elle n'est
pas soluble parce qu'il ya des tas de
gens qui croient des tas de gens qui
croient pas des gens très intelligents
des deux côtés vous dit comment est ce
que moi avec mon petit cerveau je
pourrai
les plus loin mais en fait c'est un peu
comme newton newton dit j'étais juché
sur les épaules des géants qui m'ont
précédé c'est pour ça que j'ai pu aller
plus loin et bien aujourd'hui pourquoi
est ce qu'il ya des gens qui croient
parce qu'il ya plein de raisons de
croire qu'ils sont assez intuitive
l'existence de l'univers son ordre
l'esprit tout ça a été mis en place par
la philosophie qui en a fait des raisons
de croire des preuves de l'existence de
dieu vous avez aussi des tas de choses
qui viennent de la religion donc les
miracles les apparitions les seins les
témoignages de de gens qui ont rencontré
dieu tout ça ça fait un très gros paquet
de croire en dieu ce qui fait que dans
ce pays il ya cinq siècles des siècles
un siècle tout le monde croyait en dieu
ok
la science a semblé à un moment pour
proférer un discours structuré qui était
différent mais la science vient de
changer de position aujourd'hui elle met
plutôt en difficulté les athées donc
aujourd'hui à une convergence c'est très
nouveau il ya une convergence de toutes
les indices de tout un faisceau
d'indicés si vous voulez de preuves qui
sont fortes ils sont nombreuses qui sont
rationnels qui sont indépendantes et qui
permettent d'aller vers alors après
chacun décidera tout le monde est libre
d'évaluer les choses parce que le monde
réel doit être étudié par tout le monde
mais ce qui est derrière un petit peu
c'est qui à l'aube d'une révolution si
vous voulez quelque chose qui va changer
un grand reset et puis je termine par
mon histoire un peu perso moi quand
j'avais 20 ans j'étais pas croyant est
persuadé que les croyants étaient des
gens irrationnelle qu'ils assumaient
complètement d'être irrationnels et on
m'a mis dans les mains des raisons de
croire rationnelle j'ai regardé je
croyais trouver la faille en cinq
minutes et en fait ça résister beaucoup
et je me suis aperçu que c'était très
solide si vous voulez j'ai une énorme
surprise et donc voilà cette surprise je
pense que le monde va la voir
aujourd'hui en tirant les implications
des comptes des découvertes
scientifiques des 100 dernières années
qui change complètement la donne
je remercie